[Music]
I learned a very warm welcome to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week we are focusing on
the growing international rail over the
United Nations migration pact the
document due to be adopted next month
aims to provide a framework for safe
orderly and regular migration that has
to be a good thing for the many millions
of people on the move across the world
but it's already triggered fierce debate
indeed the US Australia Israel and a
number of European countries so they
won't be endorsing the agreement which
they see is an infringement of their
sovereignty leading to further mass
migration so our question here on
quadriga this week is pact or panic can
migration be controlled and to discuss
that question I'm joined here at the
studio by three astute observers and
analysts beginning with anna alvarez
founder and CEO of migration hub that's
a network supporting social projects
working with migrants and anna argues
that we should take the pact as a
starting point for future cooperation
and civil society engagement beware
though she says the politicians alarming
narrative also with us is matthew
college snake chief europe correspondent
with political who argues that
unfortunately populist tsar poisoned the
debate to such an extent of the facts
about it don't matter and a warm welcome
to two Davalos own edith Kimani who is a
presenter and correspondent with DW
based here in berlin and Edith says
migration is as natural as the flow of
rivers we can channel it slow it down
Dam it up but it will always be on the
move the pact is an acknowledgement of
the inevitable and I'd like to begin
with you if I might the pact everybody's
talking about it it's due to be endorsed
in Marrakech Morocco in just about two
weeks time and UN Secretary General
Antonio Guterres has described it as a
truly historic agreement what makes it
so important what makes it so important
is that for the first time everyone
agreed back in 2016 that it was a topic
that needed to be discussed right of
course because of recent
was happening with the so-called crisis
in 2015 that hit Europe so so we have to
look at it historical because of that
and also because back then so it's been
18 months that the leader states so all
the members the 193 countries they had
the opportunity to have open and widely
discussions with the civil society okay
those are the states those are the
countries behind this ability but the
real question is I mean you come into
contact with migrants on a daily basis
effectively how will it affect their
lives there doesn't affect their lives
first of all they don't know about this
because at the end of the day what you
when you read on and through the the 23
points of the Global Compact are things
that should have been already
established I mean we should dignifying
migrants wherever they go number one and
number two there have been and then
there has been lots of why the
discussions in the civil society right
so I guess this is a it's a call to the
member states to always include the
migrant perspective and he did the
migration is undoubtedly a defining
issue of our global linked world at the
moment you call it and you call the pact
and acknowledgement of the inevitable
what do you mean by that basically just
what Anna said that this is something
that has been happening for decades it's
only now that the world is finally
sitting down and saying hey we need a
document that gives us a framework on
how to work around this and it's too
late I mean it's coming really quite
late and the 2015 crisis is obviously
what exacerbated it but in my opinion
this is a conversation that should have
been happening at least 10 years before
2015 you say it's too late you say it
should have happened a decade ago it's
been described by its critics as
toothless and non-binding a non-binding
compromise tell me more Lunn binding is
better than nothing in my opinion
because again going back to where the
migrants are coming from it first of all
acknowledges them as human beings
because what this document is trying to
do is establish a communication
framework between the migrants and
between the host countries why you here
what can we do for you and how do we
make it so that you are able to go back
to your countries it opens up that
dialogue if all this is so obvious why
has it come so late that's the question
I've been asking and that's why I'm
saying that it should have happened at
least 10 years before I believe it's
because Europe was finally
forced to face this in 2015 migration
has been happening in the south and
hemisphere for a very very long time and
I don't know if there any kinds of
frameworks such as this one but when the
ship started docking or the
Mediterranean Seas then the Europeans
thought wow we need to start doing
something about this now
Matthew the the pact is toothless
non-binding and it has also come out of
the blue and being badly communicated
well I wouldn't go that far I think that
a lot of people haven't been paying
attention to what the UN has been
talking about over the last couple of
years and maybe the media is partly to
blame for that the populist especially
in Europe haven't been asleep at the
switch and and they quickly seized onto
this agreement and have made it really
appear to be something that it's not I I
would I would actually say that
migration it hasn't just been an issue
for four decades I would say it's been
an issue for hundreds of years it's been
a reality for hundreds of years if not
thousands of years it's always been
something that the world has had to deal
with in various ways and this latest
discussion I think is just a way to
focus attention on it and it was
obviously driven by what happened in
2015 but it reminds me a little bit of
the Kyoto Protocol back in the early
1990s where the global community said
this is an issue that we need to pay
more attention to we need to devote more
resources about it to it and we need to
have serious discussions about it so
while it might be toothless yes on the
other hand it does establish basic
standards that most countries including
Germany and most European countries are
adhering to anyway
well actually what I would like to see
forgotten toothless and why the critics
are are saying this is because it
doesn't bring up real mechanisms how to
tackle the issue right I mean many many
critics around this they're saying okay
so how do we do it is the main question
so we deal with migration how do we do
it right so so when you have a document
which is largely baked and wants to be a
global a global issue to be discussed is
still we lack of the mechanisms and how
do we do it so let's discuss internally
about
these integrations which I would like to
include it I would like to say it about
inclusion let's talk about the inclusion
process of migrants right and perhaps
many were waiting that this Global
Compact wouldn't have said how this
process should look like or where to get
the best practices which definitely not
in Europe I think that the concept of
dealing with migration is already
defeated how do we deal inceptive
dealing with migration has already been
defeated
yeah because what are we dealing with
exactly the movement of people we've
already heard from Matthew that this is
always happen and it will continue to
happen so perhaps we need to change the
language and figure out how to deal with
irregular migration which we then call
illegal and I don't know what people in
your industry say about that but I have
a big problem with that critics on the
right would say you're moving from
illegal to irregular you're making it
less easy to prevent people from coming
to the prosperous West no if anything I
am saying that we should start looking
at why these people are moving in the
first place as opposed to trying to deal
with their movement after the fact and
that's where I think the language would
really be helpful it's interesting the
actually Matthew you're talking about it
being part of the human experience
throughout history migration people on
the move the vision and guiding
principles section of the pact actually
mentioned that and it says it is a
source of prosperity innovation and
sustainable development why is it then a
problem why is migration a problem at
all why is it being addressed as a
problem or is that the paradigm shift
that we're now seeing it's been seen a
problem and actually the right wing is
taking advantage of that and that's also
why I said we have to beware
in fact if there's no country agreeing
with this global compact then we have to
look internally into us if we don't want
a dignified and a safe migration
pathways for all the people on the move
who are we as a humanity right so let's
take a look on the people who are
compared denying this and I opposed to
this so it is definitely a narrative and
the populace are using migration these
days because it is decreasing the
migration flows are decreasing in Europe
and even in the United States well and I
think it also if we're honest it is
Challenge for society's to deal with
large influxes of of migrants and this
is also always been the case it's been
the case in in the United States if you
look back over the centuries the waves
of migrants that came to the United
States from Italy from Ireland and
places it was always controversial for a
while they were there were there was
always racism and there were always
attacks on the migrants because there
was a sense that too many of them were
coming at once and this is what you're
feeling in Europe at the moment but I
think there's too little focus on the
benefits of migration over time to
countries and especially in Europe which
is aging very rapidly they're going to
need a younger population to support
many of the systems that people you know
have become become useful you used to
hear all of the social programs and so
forth and I think that there's too
little discussion about that there's
there's a lot of discussion about the
the downsides the dangers and so forth
and there's a lot of discussion about
integration but I think you know the
real problem in Europe in especially in
in Germany I think at the moment is that
there's this sense that you can
integrate people and that nothing is
going to change in society that Germany
is going to stay just as it is and
that's that that's not the case an
integration does change society's most
people would argue many people argue for
the better but it's just it's it's
inevitable and I think this this sense
that the populace are sort of projecting
now that well if we manage migration of
or if we prevent migration then these
changes won't occur is just completely
unrealistic okay well thank you for all
that there you mentioned the United
States Matthew let's let's go to what is
currently one of the world's most
visible migration hotspots the city of
Tijuana on the US Mexican border where
thousands of Central America's mainly
from Honduras and Guatemala are hoping
to make their way to the US but
President Trump says they won't be
allowed in and among the local Mexican
population signs of aggression towards
the migrants
Mexicans are protesting against refugees
passing through their country louder and
louder beat it we don't want you they
yell get out
many of the local populations see the
migrants as an expensive burden and a
threat they sound much like US President
Trump they label the migrant caravan and
invasion the migrants sleep in
improvised shelters to keep tensions
down the authorities have imposed a
curfew
[Music]
in a minute already they have every
right to protest they don't want us here
but even so the Mexicans are good people
they're like us and we're just passing
through we don't want to stay
but they know what to expect at the
United States border can the UN
migration compact keep people from
fleeing their homes
[Music]
that's an interesting question but on
our virus what I'd like to ask you is is
somebody from the region what at what
thoughts go through your head when you
see those reports and those scenes from
the border in Tijuana it's I guess as a
humanity we have arrived to a peak of
lack of empathy you know that for many
of them they are fleeing out terrible
and violent backgrounds so they are
asylum seekers and in order to seek for
an asylum
in United States you have to be in their
lands so forbidding them it's totally
inhuman and even against the law so so
what are we talking about here right we
should we should actually reframe and
this is something that in the global
comeback and perhaps the discussions
should be an exciting point from now on
for example let's define who are
migrants let's define who are refugees
refugees are not only the ones worth
keeping wire are the ones worth keeping
danger people from Central America are
escaping danger they are prosecuted but
they're not recognized as refugees for
instance right so these are that's what
is called the aspiring migrants and they
have rights and we should protect them
and Edith what goes through your head
then given what honor has just been
saying when you hear those Mexicans
they're saying get lost beat it get away
we don't want you here I'm completely
heartbroken because I have interview
people who have been on the boats from
Africa trying to get into Europe and
they have put themselves through the
most difficult most dangerous situations
and they don't want to be doing that and
we know this because since the talks
began between Eritrea and Ethiopia on
peacebuilding the number of migrants has
reduced from those countries and it
shows that they're not going voluntarily
they would rather not actually so to
hear other people receive them as though
they are nothing not human beings in
fact that's what it does it eliminates
the dignity but it also makes migrants
objects they're just passing things and
that for me is truly heartbreaking mmm
the mayor of Tijuana said people should
be given that dignity that dignity
should be should be self-evident is that
what there is that what the pact is
going to achieve it's what it says it
aspires to do at least on paper that's
what it looks like and the big dialogue
of course
the big conversation has been on how to
implement it particularly on a country
to country basis because what Germany
thinks is dignified might not be what
Kenya for example thinks is dignified
and these are some of the blind spots
and perhaps the loopholes that the
document has that might need to be
addressed in the future but like Anna I
do agree that it's a starting point it's
a great place to begin
mm-hmm when you when you talk about the
interviews that you've had for example
the access you've had to the story would
you say that there's a I mean I know
it's very difficult to generalize
because Africa has got so many people
who are coming to Europe to set a start
better lives but they've all many
African countries or also host countries
so I'm wondering is there an African
perspective on all this the widow oh
well Africans are very good question I
know yeah but not to generalize or
anything but the general sentiment is
that of anger and despondence actually
because a Africans have been left out of
this conversation of migration for a
very long time it's only post-2015 that
the world suddenly realizes an entire
continent that's also contributing to
the flow of migrants that needs to be
put to the table that needs to be
brought into the conversation so they
were brought in a little too late and
often when the conversation of migration
comes up in the context of Africa it's
always those people who are trying to
come in how do you keep them on the
continent that's usually the frame of
the narrative so you can understand why
I'm also quite upset about that people
have an automatic human right to migrate
I don't think you should be asking me
because I'm a beneficiary of migration
to begin with what I do ultimately
that's the ironic thing I do believe
that every country has its power for
sovereignty and they do determine who
gets in and out of their borders but
just based on humanity come on people
are fleeing war they're fleeing disease
they're fleeing bad economic situations
and to turn them away without the
benefit of even assessing their
situation is unacceptable mmm Matthew
what would you say do people have a
right to migrate to countries have
the same time a right to say to people
no and turn them back and send them home
III think they do and they exercise
right and all of these countries have a
legal framework for for dealing with
these issues Germany does every European
country does the United States does I
think though that we also should
recognize the fact that a lot of
countries benefit from what is you know
referred to as a legal migration and
where I come from I grew up near that
border in in in Arizona and there was a
constant flow of illegal migrants
illegal aliens as we called them coming
over the border particularly for the for
the harvest they would work in the
fields and and and earn some money and
then and then go back to Mexico or or
farther south and this was completely
normal and both sides benefited from it
I think what has changed now is that you
know populace in particular are using
this issue to you know create these
these deep divides in the society and
and to imply that this is a danger to
you know the the the societies in in in
in the West when it's always it's always
been it's always been there not only has
it always happened why is it happening
now why is it why is the argument
suddenly so lopsided given that we know
that what three point four three three
somewhere between three and four percent
of the global population are migrants
and they generate ten percent of global
GDP these are known facts well I think I
think one factor in Europe is is the
which isn't often discussed is is the
element of Islam and the linkage that
we've seen you know the the fears of
terrorism a lot of Muslims coming into
predominantly Christian areas I think
that is what is unnerved a lot of people
and has made this latest wave somewhat
different say than what happened in the
1990s where you had the disintegration
of Yugoslavia and a lot of people coming
up from Yugoslavia and I think in the
United States the the difference is that
previously when migrants came they were
limited to you know a few areas in the
southwest of the United States where I'm
from they didn't tend to disperse into
the rest of the country and that that
has changed
recent years and Trump has recognized
that you know this is something that has
unnerved a lot of people especially in
rural communities where you know they
were they were pretty homogeneous over
over decades or over hundreds of years
and all of a sudden they have you know
little little little pockets of South
Americans living you know and on the
edge of town and and you know this is
this this is a change but you know I
think people need to accept that there
are there are benefits from it the cheap
labor that the migrants offer is is
something that all Western societies
have benefitted greatly from cheap labor
and very often very skilled people yeah
as we have seen the international
community will be meeting in Morocco
shortly to ratify the Global Compact for
safe orderly and regular migration at
least that is the idea but there's
suddenly a growing list of nations who
are changing their minds and heading for
the door the United Nations began
negotiating its migration compact in
2016 the United States never took part
last July the first to bailout was
Australia and then Hungary the
government considers the UN Global
Compact on migration as dangerous for
the entire world because it inspires
millions to leave their homes
Megan GUI anak shortly afterwards
Austria declared that it would not be
signing the compact because the term
migration was still too fuzzy then
Bulgaria opted out stating that the
compact would endanger national interest
Poland followed suit we believe that the
Marrakesh agreement is not a solution
for the migration crisis on the contrary
it would only intensify the crisis Pavel
do you check is withholding its
signature - I don't like this compact
says Czech Prime Minister Andrei Babak
Ezreal Croatia and Slovakia - almost
every day another country opt-out is the
criticism of the compact justified
it's called a global compact for
migration Edith how important is that
preposition for depends who's reading it
like Anna said if the migrants are
unaware of this then it makes no
difference it's just a high-level
conversation happening between
governments it needs to really trickle
down to the people who are affected for
those migrants because at the moment a
conversation has been hijacked as
Matthew said by the far-right and we're
focusing on what they are saying trying
to correct their erroneous statements as
opposed to really listening to the
migrants and figuring out what works for
you but what is the argument to the far
right we had the Hungarian I the Foreign
Minister and that report saying it well
it's inspiring it will inspire millions
of people to get on the move oh well
that's just outright propaganda I am
here in Germany voluntarily I have
choice and agency I wasn't brought here
by war or disease and it's still a
difficult transition it's not easy to
live in a country that's not yours I
just don't see how millions of people
could one day decide oh now that there's
this global compact I now want to go
live in Hungary No
and that just goes back to my initial
point of exclusion of the actual
migrants they don't know what's bringing
them here so they can't possibly know
what will keep them away what I really
like about the Global Compact is as I
said at the beginning the potential it
has to start a discussion at least I
have been personally invited even my
organization hosted March this year a
Global Compact consultation to the civil
society and migrant labor organizations
which was led by by to be larger
foundations that we lost to a company so
if members of the civil society which
are necessarily the government are
fostering this discussion then this is
the moment to engage States and this is
the moment to engage the larger
organizations as well to open a
discussion we have to include more
migrants more regular migrants that once
we're in the streets that ones who are
not being entrepreneurs or owning their
own organization we need to invite them
to discuss this what you were saying
about integration how this integration
look like how this affects a society it
does for the better definitely but we
see in
our resistance to the change to be open
to new cultures to be open to new
opportunities do you see a resistance to
change in Germany well I have seen a
shift in the last two years ever since I
arrived and people were welcoming
especially the ones who were fleeing out
from from the Middle East back then and
who are they right now right many of
them many projects has been created but
you have seen a shift in the narrative
you have seen the the the only fact that
I have to exist today and it's growing
in every in every region where people
are boating that is telling you
something very important elections next
year as well absolutely and other
countries like Canada for instance as
well they're going to they're going to
elections and they're also afraid that
migration is also going to be a topic
but we need to discuss about the
benefits that migration brings I was
sharing earlier that in United States
actually it was not publicly and widely
discussed that in the last decade only
from the ones who have refugee status
they contributed to the state in other
words they left 63 billion dollars in
revenues only with the ones who have a
legal status or refugee status what
about the ones that we are not tracking
their remittances for instance the ones
that we're not tracking their their
incomes so I guess that the Global
Compact could be an interesting starting
point to open the discussion and talk
about the benefits instead of thinking
that this is going to eat if I'm
interested in your final thoughts we're
running out of time they could there's a
question we set at the beginning of the
show was can migration be controlled
okay so I'd like to ask you a double
question resulting with that can
migration be controlled should migration
be controlled can migration be
controlled I think not I think it can be
regulated should it be regulated
definitely and I think in the
conversation about regulation the
powerful should also have a conversation
with themselves who's checking the
Western nations that are sending arms to
these countries who are supporting less
than democratic nations which is then
resulting
this flow of migration okay thank you
very much for those final thoughts thank
you all three for being here Matthew
Anna and Edith the that was the latest
edition of quadriga if you've enjoyed
the show and you have plenty of food for
thought which I hope it's the case join
us next week until then bye-bye and just
[Music]
you